e
[Música]
eu nunca quis ser mãe e apesar de ter
sido criada bem como toda menina para
cuidar da casa e dos filhos eu rejeitei
seu papel adorava assim brincar de
boneca de casinha até porque os meus
brinquedos se resumiam a minha
untensilios domésticos e bonecas que me
tavam bebês mas a observar as mulheres
mães da minha família realizando
atividades do cuidar eu não me sentia
atraída pelo contrário ser responsável
por uma outra vida me assustava bastante
porém como a vida se Desenrola para além
das nossas expectativas
Acabei de amamentar o Caçula dos três
filhos que tive quando engravidei do meu
primeiro filho eu tive muito medo
limitação
impossibilidade de seguir
temporariamente os meus projetos Rei e
as transformações corporais foram
desconforto dos sintomas que não deram
trégua até o último minuto da gestação e
nesse momento em que eu tava física e
emocionalmente vulnerável eu me
questionava onde estão as grávidas
compartilhando sobre os mesmos Desafios
que mencionavam eu não mas encontrava
estavam todas lindas
radiantes e grátis o tempo todo por
estarem gerando um serzinho tão amado e
desejado de um lado as amigas super
empolgados com o início das aulas do
curso de grávida do outro lado a gente
sociais
abarrotados de gravidez exibindo seus
barrigões ensaios fotográficos super
produzidos com legendas do tipo vou
sentir falta do barrigão enquanto eu
contava as horas para me despedir dos
enjôos azia as dores falta de posição
para dormir e o cansaço sem fim não era
possível que elas não sentiram dores nem
cansaço e nem frustração Eu acreditei
que o programa de ver se está em mim né
com a minha falta de conexão instantânea
com o bebê né tão como as grávidas eu
não me senti à vontade para falar com a
minha barriga quase não a tocava sequer
me pegava imaginando como seria o
rostinho do meu bebê não não Foi
espontâneo com me disseram que seria na
verdade é só conexão nem aconteceu
durante a gestação e nem tô sabendo que
cada mulher se relacione vivenciar a
gestação de maneira particular Os
relatos sobre gestar eram muito o
padronizados exemplos de reclamação e as
poucas reclamações eram seguidas de
justificativas né para não deixar
transparecer algum vestígio de não
gratidão e não era algo que fazia
sentido para mim afinal eu enxergava
mais contras do que prós e atrelados a
criação de um filho dentro da minha
realidade trabalhando por conta própria
e sem rede de apoio mais tarde quando a
segunda filha que apesar de não
planejada me afetou de maneira
surpreendente quase dois anos após a
morte do seu irmão meu primeiro filho eu
senti prazer em estar gestão de você mas
nem esse sentimento de novos
possibilidades de cor para os nossos
dias antes de tão cinzentos me impediu
de ser isolada pela crise da
desconstrução EA readaptação a novos
papéis nesse momento voltar a trabalhar
fora já não era mais uma opção viável né
somado isso a quantidade de demandas que
mesmo com o apoio do meu companheiro que
não acabavam quando eu deitava a cabeça
no travesseiro que acontece a todo
instante além da sobrecarga algumas
mulheres que me esquisito eu não me
enquadro ainda carregam crenças
obrigações valores que se somam e se
acumulam né com a chegada de um novo
membro à família e que acabam pesando de
maneira desproporcional na qualidade de
vida saúde a par dessas mulheres quando
ainda existe uma ditadura social em que
o padre ser do paraíso é a única forma
válida de maternagem não existir em
relação para o apoio compreensão
acolhimento entre pessoas que vivem root
mas parecidos né inclusive facilmente
observadas nas escolas parquinhos e hoje
nas redes sociais que qualquer forma
independente do grau de aceitação
envolvimento e até mesmo quando a
gravidez é planejada não há isenção
desse mergulho hormonal que quando não
nos afoga pelo menos encharcado não é a
novidade de ser mãe é
desestabilizadora que acaba interferindo
diretamente nas emoções das Gestantes
são três trimestres de mudanças físicas
e emocionais isso porque geram Zezinho
dependente totalmente indefeso é como
sofreu uma de 100 mil vezes mais
hormônios do que o que está acostumado e
sim os hormônios são os culpados Por que
apesar de bem intencionados os efeitos
colaterais da vulnerabilidade das
emoções chegam com força então eu
entendi após compartilhar experiências
nas redes e ouvir tantas outras que não
era um problema meu né era um problema
social Cultural de silenciamento de
cobrança de contabilização da mulher mãe
pois independente do que a mulher esteja
sentindo o vivendo ela não encontra um
espaço seguro para compartilhar seus
reais sentimentos medos e inseguranças
angústias desejos estão encontra
polimento na sociedade que além de não
permitir ainda cobra Felicidade Plena um
nesse momento tão Sublime de completude
e essa forma de relacionamento com a
maternidade é uma construção social
iniciada lá na Idade Média quando existe
uma dica organização da Maternidade de
vida é conferida ao poder paternal
então laços afetivos eram desnecessários
para manutenção familiar porém muitos
bebês morriam e para reduzir essa
mortalidade ouve a exaltação ao amor
materno na como uma forma de beneficiar
tanto a espécie como a sociedade por
qual incentivava a mãe assumir o cuidado
da prole essa forma começa a ser visto
como inadmissível não está feliz e crema
nesse momento mágico né se eu não quer a
versão romanceada da Maternidade ela não
leva em consideração
a humanidade da mulher mãe sabe meu
primeiro filho que morreu então tentaram
me culpabilizar por sua morte alegando
falta de amor e felicidade enquanto eu
geravam É sim
diante disso é necessário e urgente que
pensávamos a maternidade como uma
construção sócio-histórica e cultural e
não mais como um dom natural as mulheres
dessa forma todas as experiências
poderão ser respeitadas e valorizadas
pelo Direito da mulher viver a
pluralidade conforme seu desejo e assim
contribuir para Que tantas outras
mulheres não se sintam inadequadas nos
seus processos justamente o porquê a
mídia EA sociedade criam falso glamour a
respeito dessa fase que tipo amorosa tem
pouquinho se uma coisa e assim impedindo
que manifestações honestas nos liberte
das amarras e patriarcais que insistem
em desumanizar as mulheres Mães